- This is very cozy.
(cheering)
I'm short.
- Moving the pillows, I know.
- I'm really short.
- I know,
In my legs, I have no legs.
I am all torso.
- I've got nothin'.
So if I don't put 75 pillows,
I end up sitting like Edith Ann.
I look like that.
- Was it Lily Tomlin in the big chair.
- That's Edith Ann, yes.
- Oh is that a character?
- Every time I sit somewhere I'm like
pretty sure that's what it looks like.
- I know,
'cause tall people always
complain about being on planes,
but short people, it sucks,
'cause you lose your circulation
'cause your feet don't touch the floor.
- It's very difficult for short people
you tall people.
- I don't want to hear all
your tall people problems.
You are perfect to host Little Big Shots.
(cheering)
You are.
It's so cool.
How did this come about?
And what are you most
excited about the show?
- Kind of all of that.
When it first came up I was like,
"No I shouldn't do that.
"That seems crazy."
- That's what I said about this.
Watch out.
- Uh oh.
- Yeah.
- You do start to feel like,
that's not really what I do.
I don't want to screw it up
for kids, was my main thing.
All these great kids are
coming on and I'm like,
Am I gonna be weird?
Am I gonna say something that
they're like, "That's odd."
(laughter)
I didn't know the format.
- It builds character.
They'll be fine.
- I come out in a wig.
When we kind of started messing,
because we really changed the format.
I'm like, I want it
less performance driven
and more, what are these kids up to?
They're just doing things,
and they're so in their own
skin at such an early age.
I just think there's so much.
People get so much attention
for really being cruel.
And then you have kids like Ella
who's the kid governor for Connecticut.
She's so funny.
She's exactly like her 11
year old self in a kid.
Look at that face!
She's so cute.
- [Kelly] Look at the eye brows.
I love it.
- [Melissa] She's such a riot.
- [Kelly] Just attitude.
She goes, "I want my
kids to read about hatred
"and what homophobia is in the textbooks
"because I want them to
not know what it is."
And I was just like, "I'm sorry, what?"
She's like, "I want them
to read about it in history
"and for me to have to explain it to them.
"That's what my goal is."
- [Kelly] That's amazing.
(applause)
- All these kids have so many,
their heart is so big, and
their conviction's so strong.
It's a big thing at any
age to just be like,
I know it's not what everybody's doing,
but I'm okay with it.
- To see the world through
their eyes would be wonderful.
If we could just stop and slow down.
- I would like just a non aerosol spray.
I would love to just be
like, "You seem mean."
Like just spray you with a seven year old.
(laughter)
If I cold bottle that and just
run arounds spraying people.
Somehow that clip will be taken out
and will seem very weird later.
Just talk about macing people.
(laughter)
- You're a turd.
- That seemed better before I said it.
I seem like a real weirdo now.
- You gotta bring humor into it,
and I think that's why they
obviously wanted you too
because you have a very great heart,
but you're also very
humorous and you have kids.
Speaking of your kids,
are they little big shots?
Do they do stuff that really shock you?
- They shock me a lot.
They're perfectly weird and funny
in the best way.
- So they're you.
(laughter)
- Between me, Ben, my husband,
is much quieter and mellower,
but he's super weird.
I'm not gonna let him off the hook.
Our kids are this weird
amalgamation of us.
And then you really start to
see their own selves come in.
So I see me.
I see Ben.
I always think, I'm like,
"If I just don't screw
you up it'll be amazing."
If I had it my way I would
stuff them both in a Baby Bjorn.
- Like a kangaroo.
- For sure, and I'm always like,
"Just sit up here."
My oldest is 12, but she's my height now.
And I'm literally always like, "Come here.
"Come here."
- Get on over here!
- I know, I'm like, "Get
right here on mama's lap."
She's like, "That's just odd.
"I'm wearing your shoes.
"I don't want to sit on your lap."
(laughter)
- Rude.
(cheering)
It's All the Feels February on this show.
- Oh, all the feels.
- And nothing gives us all the feels
like our families and friends.
So if you're up for it,
I'd love to scroll through your Instagram
'cause you've got a great Instagram.
I want to meet some of
your family and friends.
Is that cool?
- Sure.
I'm like, "What is it?"
- Here we go.
Let's see the first one.
- Oh my gosh.
That is a long time ago.
We look like kids in that.
- [Kelly] So wait, explain this to us.
- I think that Ben and I, oh god.
I bet we had just,
we might have been at
Groundlings, the improv theatre.
- [Kelly] What a great place to meet.
- We met in class.
We were both still in our 20's for sure.
- [Kelly] Wow.
- I look at that I'm like,
"Look at how hopeful we were."
(laughter)
- That's what hope looked like.
- Full of energy,
sleeping full through nights.
It's wonderful.
- [Kelly] Who needs that?
- Oh my god.
- What's next?
Let's see the next one?
(laughter)
- Oh god.
I'd like to explain.
(laughter)
Sadly, I'd like to say
the one with the tiny hat,
which by the way was
from Barbie Western Wear.
I'd love to say it was
a joke or a character.
It wasn't.
I was told when I got to LA
because I had only done plays in New York.
I finally was like, "I'm
getting a commercial agent."
I wasn't, but I was going
to meet with someone.
And he said, "If you
want to work in this town
"you've got to do character shots",
and I was like, "Oh I think
those make me uncomfortable."
I said, "Is that when
someone's in a cop jacket
"and the next thing they're the burglar?"
I was like, "I don't
think I want to do that."
And he's like, "Well then
you don't want to work,
"and you can't work with me."
I didn't know it was supposed to be like
things you may get cast as
like a waitress or a cop.
So I went to do that
headshot and I was like,
"This is Carol.
"She works at a Vaughan's."
(laughter)
What you can't see is
under the picture I'm
holding a plastic tray
with Velveeta slices on it.
(laughter)
And I had a whole thing I was like,
"She works in a grocery
store at the end of an aisle,
"and she passes out cheese samples."
- [Kelly] She's about
to whip up some Rotel.
- I brought that back to
my agent and he was like,
"What the hell is this?"
(laughter)
He's like, "What does
this mean to anyone?"
I'm like, "I don't know.
"I said I didn't want to do it."
- It stands out.
- It sure did.
No one ever calls me in on that
because I look crazy.
- Their loss.
That's what I say.
Next.
(cheering)
- Can you always speak on my behalf?
(laughter)
Oh that's my mom.
- [Kelly] That's awesome.
- I think we were at the Oscar's luncheon.
(applause)
That's my mom.
- You're at the Oscar's luncheon?
What's the Oscar's luncheon?
- It's like a fever dream.
You show up and you're just like,
"Someone's gonna ask me
to leave in a minute."
(laughter)
If you're nominated there's
an Oscar's luncheon,
and you go and it's
just the nominees there.
You can bring a date, and
I brought my mom Sandy.
- That's awesome.
Hey Sandy.
Okay, next.
Oh god I love the hair.
- Just permed, so many perms back then.
- [Kelly] So many perms.
- That's my sister Margie.
I bet I'm in grade school
maybe she's in high school,
and we just did lots of perms
and then just so much All
Net and a curling iron.
- Oh my god the Aqua Net and
you'd hold it out with a dryer.
- Crispy, crispy, open,
(clicks tongue) ringlet.
And then sometimes you'd only get to here
and you'd get tired.
I'd have all these huge ringlets
and the back was just like (moans).
- Like you got a little
version of a mullet hair cut.
- Yeah that was down time hair.
If we were going out it was like...
- That's so Texan.
Okay next.
Oh my gosh I love this.
- You know you make some
choices sometimes that are...
- [Kelly] It's a nice denim choice.
- I think my mom and dad were like,
"We want to have nice
pictures of you girls taken."
- I think it's awesome.
- For some reason Margie and I were like,
"We should wear matching denim shirts
and do like the cop poster back to back."
- I love it.
It's very Charlie's Angels.
- Sure.
Without any of the coolness.
- I love denim girl.
You're talkin' to a Texan.
- I love denim,
but just somehow we've
gone off the mark on that.
(laughter)
- You did not.
Next.
Let's see the next one.
Oh my gosh they're little lions.
- They are.
That's still Harper and Homer.
- They're Golden Retrievers?
- They're Golden Retrievers,
and I got these Amazon lion things.
And when they showed up
they're made of just old syringes.
They're terrible,
(laughter)
but they were the exact
same colors as my dogs.
So I put them on I was
out in the back yard
trying to get two crazy one
year old dogs to sit still.
And then he yawned and I'm like, "Yep.
- Yep.
(laughter)
But it looks like a (roars)
- They never went on again.
They truly look like lions.
- I love it.
I love it.
The old syringe look.
(laughter)
Alright one more, we've got one more.
Oh my god, you're dying.
You're laughing.
Wait, what's happening?
- Oh my god I don't
remember putting that on.
That is two of my dearest
friends in the world.
It's Brian Atwood, who's
a fantastic shoe designer,
and then Michael McGraw.
I went to high school with Brian,
Michael I met on the dance
floor of the Palladium
in the '90s.
And I marched up to him and said,
"That's the ugliest jacket I've ever seen.
"I love it."
And we have never been apart since.
- Oh my god.
- That was us in Vegas.
- Do you remember what you're laughing at?
Or is it not daytime worthy?
- It's for sure not daytime worthy.
I can't remember,
but that is probably what we
look like 90% of the time.
- [Kelly] Those are great friends.
You need to laugh.
- [Melissa] They were both
my bridesmen for my wedding.
- Oh my gosh that's awesome.
I hope you asked him to wear the jacket.
(laughter)
Just wear that number.
- Just wear it, come one.